- I'm really excited to introduce
my colleague, Jim Scott,
who is a graduate of the
Moorestown Friends School
in New Jersey, as well
as other fine schools.
He's the author of
several important books,
some of which you have probably heard of.
I'd call the books classics,
but unlike classics,
some people actually
enjoy reading Jim's books.
He's a sterling professor of
political science here at Yale
but we in anthropology
really appreciate it
when he calls himself an
honorary anthropologist.
And we in the Southeast
Asian Studies Council
really need to thank Jim
for the mountains of merit
that he has accrued on
our behalf over the years.
In Burma, like other parts
of Theravada Southeast Asia,
merit making entails the act of giving,
cultivating virtue and mental development.
And I think it suffices to say
that Jim does all of those things.
He's a man of many good
deeds and much merit
and it's a real pleasure
to introduce him today
for his talk on Irrawaddy.
So Jim, take it away.
- Thanks a lot, Eric, for
that generous introduction.
I wanna begin actually, by noticing
as you all have perhaps noticed yourselves
that we are well into our second week
of the military coup in Burma.
And there are a whole series of efforts
that are underway to provide
some international support
for the nonviolent resistance in Burma.
There are gonna be other opportunities
including efforts to
raise subsistence funds
for all the doctors and teachers
and civil servants who were on strike.
And I have contributed actually
a good part of my royalties
for the last 10 years to
the Assistance Association
for Political Prisoners in Burma.
It's an association of ex prisoners
that takes care of prisoners
by sending them food,
medicines, taking care of their families
and taking care of them when
and if they're released.
And so I think Chris will
put up the easiest way
to contribute is via the
campaign for the Rohingya
in which the money would be forwarded
to the Assistance Association
for Political Prisoners.
They provide, by the way
if you go to their website, AAPP(Burma),
they provide a daily briefing
on what's happening in Burma now.
And I recommend that as a source
for day-to-day information
on the current situation
in Burma, so thank you.
And I'll move now to my talk if I may.
The talk is called in praise of floods.
I've been teaching a seminar on rivers
called rivers nature and politics
for the last seven or eight years.
And historically I've done
actually a fair amount
of canoeing and fishing on American rivers
and spent a long time on
the Irrawaddy in Burma
until the pandemic.
And in fact, although I was
interested in the river itself,
the river was also partly an excuse for me
that I wanted to make sure that no matter
where I was in Burma
that if the police asked what I was doing
I could say I was studying the Irrawaddy
because I would always
be close to a tributary
or distributary of the Irrawaddy
no matter where I was in Burma
although that would not
hold if I were in Kenton
in this sort of Eastern (indistinct)
But I date germ of this talk actually
to an encounter I had
something like 20 years ago.
I found myself at a conference
in which there were hydrologists
and Southeast Asians
the two separate meetings going on
but we were all at the
same conference site
and they wanted us to be good
companions to one another.
So they ordered us at lunch and dinner
to intersperse ourselves
and carry on conversations
across disciplines and interests.
And I found myself sitting
next to a very smart
and interesting Philippine hydrologist
and trying to be a good boy
and make conversation with him.
I tried to think, well,
what can we talk about?
And I had learned in the
last two or three years
before this meeting
that the Colorado River
never got to the sea for
a large part of the year.
And I was sad for the Colorado River,
it seemed to me all our
metaphors about rivers
running to the sea, that it
just gave me a sense of sympathy
for the Colorado, that it
didn't get to do its thing
and run to the sea,
like all rivers should.
And so I tried to start conversation
by saying to the hydrologists
that I learned this
about the Colorado wasn't too bad,
that Colorado didn't get to the sea.
And he turned to me very quickly
and with a stentorian voice
and said, no, no, it's
the most wonderful thing
in the world, it means that
every drop of the Colorado River
is used for some important purpose
and not a drop goes to waste.
And I realized from that
moment, we were probably
not gonna have a long conversation
because he was if you like,
interested in the functionality
for homo sapiens of the river and the uses
to which it could be put.
He was not alone,
and here, I want to
quote Winston Churchill
on the the Nile River.
And I quote, "One day
every last drop of water,
which drains into the
whole valley of the Nile
shall be equally and amicably divided
among the river people
and the Nile itself
shall perish gloriously
and never reach the sea."
Joseph Stalin, who was less
given to ornamental pros,
put it more succinctly,
"Water which is allowed to
enter the sea is wasted."
You could have had similar
things spoken by anyone
from the American Bureau of Reclamation
or the Army Corps of Engineers
until very, very recently.
I want to begin actually with assertion
that everything moves
and rivers too of course,
but it seems to me that
one of the problems
is that humans are inclined
to thinking of units over human life.
And we don't think of river
time, of mountain time,
of truly time and so on,
let alone smaller units like
insect time, you might say,
but if you open the
temporal lens wide enough,
everything moves.
And my illustration of this,
let's see if this works,
oh, there we go.
This is 120,000 year video of the movement
of the polar ice cap.
You can see it moving.
And how many thousand years ago is up
in the upper left-hand corner?
You will see that 17 or 18,000 years ago
was the last Glacial
Maximum after which the ice,
the polar cap retreats
and continues retreating today, of course.
But you see in the enormous
variation over time.
Rivers, like the St. Lawrence Seaway,
were essentially the
breaking up of a glacial Lake
called Lake Agassi right after
the last Glacial Maximum.
So now that's the last Glacial Maximum,
and then there's the retreat.
The picture I would have
preferred to show you
although I couldn't get an animation of it
is that after the last Glacial Maximum,
we think of trees for
example, as being static
and being not moving.
But in fact, they're moving all the time
and it's again opening the temporal lens.
So if you were to have a
time elapsed photograph
after the last Glacial Maximum,
you would see century by
century, the oaks and the beaches
moving North from the Mediterranean
as the climate improved
and things got warmer.
And so the trees would be moving
and bringing together
with them their soils,
the insects, the animals and so on
that are part of the larger
ecosystem of arboreal forest.
I want to next move to, there we go,
these are actually prepared by
the Army Corps of Engineers.
This is about a thousand year depiction
of the different bends and channels
of the Mississippi River.
The white portion is the current channel
of the Mississippi River,
but you get some sense for
where the Mississippi has been
and some sense for where it might go,
were it not(indistinct).
This is another version of the river,
I think near St. Louis,
if I'm not mistaken.
The other example that's quite famous,
is the Yellow River estuary.
There are major shifts North and South
of the Shandong Peninsula from 2200 BC.
And the second slide shows shifts
in the major distributaries
of the Yellow River
in the last two centuries alone.
It's a huge variation,
and in fact, the second to last movement
of the major channel of
the Yellow River to sea
was in 1938 when Chiang
Kai-shek broke the dykes
of the Yellow River in
order to send it South
in order to impede the
Japanese advance to the North.
It was successful, but
it cost 300,000 lives.
The process of this change has all to do
with the gradient of the coastal plain.
That is to say, if the
gradient is very low,
the river slows down and as it slows,
the sedimentaries settles
out and raises the river bed.
Over time itself damming,
that is to say it creates
its own levee ahead of it
and then it spreads laterally
and seeks another path to the sea.
As a new channels cloud over time,
the river may go back to an older channel
that is now a faster way to the sea.
The process is natural,
though the amount of sediment
can vastly be increased of course,
by deforestation in the watershed.
And of course the river is
likely to build new land
in the estuary itself.
Each flood raises the land flooded
by the deposition of sediment
so that the floodplain of
the middle mile, for example,
is now 10 feet higher than
it was 5,000 years ago.
George Perkins Marsh actually
understood all of this
in his magnificent book, "Man
and Nature" published in 1864.
Thus river port towns and coastal towns
that are river's mouth or
vulnerable to being blocked
by the buildup of silt and sand.
The most famous example
of this, I think is Bruges,
the great linen center
it's river, the artery
and the artery that made it Bruges
as a linen center was the Zwijn River.
It's silted up in the 15th century
and the merchants left for Antwerp
leaving this urban 16th century gem
as a kind of museum piece
that we can admire today.
On the Upper Rhine for
example, (indistinct)
in Roman times it was on the left bank
and the 10th century it was on an island,
in the 13th century on
the left bank again,
and in the 14th century up until today,
it was on the right bank.
So this movement is constant over time
and in my personal experience,
we have a summer cabin
in Central Pennsylvania, which
we would go to every summer
for the better part of a
decade with the children.
And I observed each year, the
what's called the accretion
or carving out by the ice in the spring
of each meander and had the
sense for the slow change
in the course of the river.
But I was misled by this
gradual change because in 1972
there was a huge flood.
I realized that 99% of
the change in this Creek
came during the high water
of this massive flood,
two or three hours, right in 1972
that cut off meanders,
leaving oxbows and so on
and that this is called in
international law avulsion
rather than accretion.
And that most of the
great changes in the river
are these catastrophic events
of massive high water moments.
I want to show, this is the
process of creating oxbows.
This is an oxbow that
has been recently cut off
as you can see.
And the next flood you can see an oxbow
that whose lifetime is limited probably
to the next great flood,
because that loop to your left
will be cut off as well.
I'm going to leave up
of the Irrawaddy River
Which its major tributaries to the North
of the Malikha and Maika that join
to create the Irrawaddy North of Myitkyina
that then flows South Mandalay,
it's joined by the Chindwin
and if I had a map of
the Irrawaddy over time
it's been changed radically,
it's channeled by volcanic events.
The Sittaung River was in fact the channel
of the Irrawaddy to the
sea in geological times
and after the eruption of
Mount Popa and (indistinct)
the bank of the Irrawaddy
was changed quite radically.
The Irrawaddy is moving all the time,
and I want to give you a sense of this.
On one trip downstream, from Mandalay
to the ancient capital of
Bagan, it was a day's trip
a small inboard motor boat
carrying no more than 20 passengers.
What was interesting to me
is that we used four pilots
whom we picked up along the way,
and each of these pilots was an expert
in a section of the river
and essentially a two
hour sail down the river.
And after their knowledge
ran out, they would get off
and we would take on another
pilot who was an expert
for the next little patch of the river
and these people had worked at
these jobs for 20, 30 years.
So the captain of the
boat who've been going
up and down the Irrawaddy for a long time,
he did not trust himself to
understand the different shifts
in the sandbanks and channel
day by day and week by week,
without using these pilots.
And still in this case,
we didn't get stuck,
but in many cases, even with these pilots
it's not very uncommon to be stuck.
And the larger cargo carriers
especially during low
water in February and March
the danger was much greater than many
of the larger cargo carriers
that are irretrievably stuck
and have to wait until the monsoon season
in order to be floated off the mud banks
or sandbanks in which they're embedded.
Next, I want to show,
this is a common site on some
of the larger passenger boats.
And you see that long bamboo
pole, and it is a depth gauge.
There are two of them, usually
at the prow of each boat.
And when they are in shallow waters,
there are two people
shouting out the depth
of the river from both
sides of the boat, actually.
And they're yelling more than five feet
or less than four feet,
et cetera, et cetera.
And this is exactly kind
of Mark Twain's point
on life of the Mississippi
marking on the twine,
is the equivalent of the
Mississippi river boats
that had to do precisely the same thing.
And still, it was very common
for (indistinct) to get stuck.
You may wonder what these
people are doing in the water.
First of all, notice how
shallow it is, right?
This passenger boat has become stuck,
and what they've done is to
send two or three members
of the crew out, and they have
a stake and other close up
they have a stake, which they embed
in the sand of the river.
They will then attach that to a cable
which will then be attached to a winch
at the back of the boat
that will winch it in
and winch it out and the idea is to wiggle
the prow of the boat until
it can be backed off the bank
in which it's embedded.
The engines are of course going in reverse
but the winching is necessary
in order to unembed it.
And that's why actually
the ships going downstream
and lower have the right of way,
because if you get stuck going downstream
the current is your enemy
because it embeds you deeper
and it's harder to back off.
Whereas the ships going upstream
don't have the right of way,
because it's much easier
for them to get off.
The variation over time...
One more thing about
rivers as living things,
it helps to tell us that ideas
such as the a hundred year
flood or 50-year flood
that you hear all the
time in weather reports
and disaster reports is,
and I choose my words carefully nonsense.
That is to say, for example, the Rhine,
had four 100-year floods in 12 years
in 1983, '88, '93 and '94.
That should give one some pause
over the meaning of a hundred year flood.
Why?
For most rivers, not quite all of them
we simply don't have
the statistical series
on water levels and volume flows
that go back more than
a hundred, 200 years,
which would even in principle
allow us to make such a
statistical generalization.
Now the Yellow River or
the Yangtze or the Rhine
or Danube or Euphrates are
partial exceptions to this,
and we have a longer statistical series.
But more important, even if
we did have a deep series,
the assumption behind
the a hundred year flood
and the 50-year flood
is the assumption of
hydrological equilibrium,
but it's not the same
river from year to year.
It's moving silt and sand and clay,
it's carving new channels and meanders,
it's normal flood stage is
building natural levees.
And if we add anthropogenic
changes in particular
it's radically not the same river.
That is to say in 1800 most
of the Mississippi bank
was forested, but by 1960,
95% was planted to agricultural crops.
Forget about all the other interventions
which are made into the river.
My problem in my seminar with the students
on rivers was that
they're mostly interested
in actually like the Philippine
hydrologist I mentioned,
they're interested in
the uses of the river,
for homo sapiens, for drinking water
for irrigation, et cetera, flood control.
And I hope when I write the
book about the Irrawaddy,
because I have a lot of data
on fish migrations and so on
and migrations of birds and
riverine mammals as well,
to talk more about all those creatures
that depend on the river
for their life world,
including clams and mussels,
shellfish, shell and larvae.
The most important movement in
the annual life of the river
is what is called the flood pulse.
It's a very, I think
important choice of terms
that is to say that part of the year
during which the river
overflows its natural channel
and occupies its habitual floodplain.
The pulse of high water
may come from the monsoon,
from snow or glacial melt
or from seasonal rainfall.
And it may be of different
degrees of variability
but it is a completely natural part
of the annual cycle of a river.
The flooding of the floodplain
represents the lungs
of a river in a literal sense.
That is to say the
condition of it's vitality
and its nutrition and that of
the creatures who depend on it
without the annual flooding
of the floodplain, the channel
which we usually associate
with the river at rest
in our paintings and photographs
is comparatively dead,
biologically speaking.
Flood as a scare word is
so deeply anthropogenic
that I want to ban its use
but it's not in my power.
It's just the river breathing as it must.
On this view, we would understand
a flooding of settlements
near the river as the result
of homo sapiens encroaching
on the natural plane of the river,
that is to say an act of trespass.
The periodic flooding of the
floodplain is the life world
and condition of existence
of all of the species
that inhabit the river or
who dwell along the river.
And here, this is an effort
by a disturbance ecologist
to show you how the level
of a river over time
brings nutrients to
higher and higher ground,
and then retreats.
Fish, for example, get as much as 80%
of their total annual nutrition
from the huge pulse of food
that the flood stage affords,
as they spread out over the floodplain.
There, they spawn and put on weight,
they feed on the invertebrates,
decaying organic matter,
the microbes that are on the floodplain.
There's almost always a
huge migration of fish
to take advantage of this feeding frenzy
anadromous fish that come in
from the sea for that matter,
are there in partly in large
part for this sea pulse event.
The floodplain may be 40
times wider than the channel
in places like the Amazon,
where there's a huge variation.
You have fruit eating fish
for the simple reason,
that the water level gets so
high, that the fish can profit
from what we call the low hanging fruits
that are on the adjacent banks.
The Mississippi fish catch had declined
more than 80% in the years up to 1993.
But the result of the 1993 massive flood
was that the fish catch
the year afterwards
was a new record and the year
after that also a new record
because of the spawning and
greater population of fish.
The studies of the Danube
have shown that the greater
the extent of the flooded a given year,
the greater the haul of fish.
By the way, it's not just fish of course,
but a whole cavalcade
of all those creatures
that depend on a
concentration of nutrition.
Waterfowl who were there
because the birds are there,
and the (indistinct), the way
in which fishermen can tell
that there's a migration of fish coming,
is that the birds appear
before the fish migrate
because they've in a sense
learned further downstream
that the fish are on the way
and they precede the fish
and wait for their feast.
And the fishermen then know
it's time to get out of the nets
and get ready for the migration of fish.
Waterfowl and riverine wetland
birds in the West Heron,
muskrats, fox, wolves Raptors herbivores,
will come for the fresh grouse, excuse me,
fresh grass sprouting
after the flood recedes,
and all the microparasites
that feed on this cavalcade.
And then as the flood recedes,
much of this nutrition
returns to the channel where
some of the larger fish,
channel cats and dolphins
can benefit from it,
as well as the comparatively
immobile, shellfish, clams
and bottom larvae.
That is to say the flood pulse
brings back to the channel
nutrition that it would not otherwise have
that it collects if you
like from the floodplain.
So what the flood does
in one sense is to provide connectivity.
It moves water over the landscape
creating a huge variety of
habitats, backwaters, ponds
marsh environments, moving
water, a warmer water, refugees
or refuges from larger predators,
varied assemblages of food and habitat
that favor different riverine species.
The whole mechanism depends
on the microbial richness
of the floodlight that represents the base
of the food pyramid
and the entire life world of the river.
Without the flood pulse then,
the river is comparatively dead.
I mean to emphasize non-human species here
but let me say a bit
about what the flood pulse
does for homo sapiens,
the most numerous and most
successful invasive species
the world has known.
Well, what it does is civilization,
no floodplain, no civilization.
That's something that
was slight exaggeration
but not a great exaggeration exception.
(indistinct) or archaic civilizations
were founded on floodplains,
often near the estuary of a river.
Why?
That's the only place where
you can have a concentration
of foodstuffs and people
in a small circumference
in which state making is possible.
Observe what the flood does.
It drowns all the competing
vegetation, AKA weeds,
it lays down a layer of nutritious silt
that provides nutrients to the crops.
Usually cereal grains.
It provides if it's well behaved
as the Nile Valley generally
is a perfectly harrowed field
ready for sowing, no plowing needed,
just broadcast the seeds.
In a sense, the flood
does the agricultural work
except for the sowing and the harvesting.
And the same way, by the way,
if you, the comparable case
for inland agriculture
in the hills is shifting
or fire field cultivation
or/and burn cultivation
in which the job of that water does
in what I call flood
recession agriculture,
the job that fire does is
exactly what water does
in flood recession agriculture.
That is to say it burns organic matter,
provides fertilizer and
all the other fields
have to be moved from time to time.
It's essentially the same process.
Hence the oldest form of agriculture
is called flood recession agriculture
or in French (speaks in foreign language).
It's also common in Eastern
Woodland agriculture
among native Americans.
These would be the places along streams
that were annually flooded,
that would be the places
where native Americans
would do early planting.
Make sure I've got them, there we go.
This is an island in the upper Irrawaddy
and it is completely flood
recession agriculture.
And it is something like five or 600 acres
that is recreated every year
and that six villages share
or fight about, I should say
in terms of who gets what
because this patch is changing every year
depending on the
accumulation of silt and soil
but it's a major agricultural site
and there is bamboo bridge
rebuild nearly two miles long
built every year in
order that people can get
from one bank to this
island in the middle.
And in the Delta and the Irrawaddy
Delta, there are hundreds
and hundreds of such islands
with complicated forms
of property rights with efforts to shore
up property rights by
driving in bamboo stakes
and making sure that the new
silt accumulates on their side
of the island rather than
on other side of the island.
So it's a whole world in which our sense
of if you like land staying
in place, doesn't hold,
and it is if you like shifting floodplains
that are in the middle of a river
or off shore from its banks
The best way of understanding this,
is through what is often
called disturbance ecology.
I don't like the term disturbance
because it risks obscuring the fact
that floods are often annual,
natural, unfairly predictable.
That is to say, they're
not disturbances at all
or such disturbances are normal
cyclical, but it is proposed
in contrast to distinction,
to equilibrium analysis,
in which the succession and distribution,
efficient insects and birds
reached a terminal state
that was stable.
As we shall see, it's the prevention
or the forceful stopping of
these natural perturbations,
that is the real disturbance,
the real intervention
the attempt to enforce
a permanent equilibrium.
Natural disturbances create new mosaics
with plants and animals, insects.
They open the canopy, they
destroy or displace species
but they begin a new
succession of colonists.
The result is more biodiversity
in terms of the variety of species
and this mosaic of patches
that is in turn more resilient.
It's worth recalling what
the flood accomplishes,
it eliminates much previous vegetation,
it's soaks the soil deeply,
it brings in nutritious silt,
and it is an open and inviting environment
waiting to be colonized
by flood adapted marine life,
by flood adapted insect life
by flood adaptive flora
seeds that have been waiting
for a long, long time.
Quick colonizing species
from adjacent patches,
a slower colonization from further away,
it's a favorable spawning environment
for a selection of fish, insects and birds
who do best in uncrowded
open environments.
It creates then innumerable
edge environments
or ecotones that are, as we know,
species rich because they provide access
to two or more environments,
sometimes seasonal.
This is what happens without humans,
humans can use and shape this process.
So along the Nile, just poking a hole
in the natural levees of
the river at a flood stage
could inundate the back slopes and hollows
with silt rich water.
And then when the water had soaked in,
one could plant wheat or
barley, no state was needed.
So if you like the agriculture
along the Nile River
was a completely village
affair had nothing to do
with Pharaohs and state-like
entities creating irrigation.
Flood recession agriculture is simplest,
it just uses nature to
work with a little nudge.
Now, how am I doing in terms
of time, Eric, five minutes?
- You have a little bit
more than five minutes.
- I'm sorry, I've got to put on my, yeah.
- You have five minutes.
- Okay, good, what we've done with rivers
is to simplify them by engineering.
Humankind has of course
been sculpting rivers
for its purposes forever.
But only with the invention of dynamite
in 1870 and subsequent
earth moving machinery
and reinforced concrete
as this sculpting taken
on protean proportions.
As you know, one of the interesting things
about the Irrawaddy,
is that the Irrawaddy
does not have any dams
on its main stem.
The effort to build a dam at the Myitsone
at the origin of the Irrawaddy,
which was underway actually
and was stopped by actually
a democratic movement
and general's compliance with
that democratic movement.
There are lots of dams north
of the origin of the Irrawaddy
on the tributaries that
contribute to the Irrawaddy
and they've had a huge
effect on the hydrology
of the Irrawaddy, but the Irrawaddy itself
is so far an undammed river.
The engineering of rivers
is I like to think of it
as some combination of
taxidermy and amputation
because the simplification of the effort
of these intervention is
usually to simplify the river
and to have it serve a
single functional purpose.
The Rhine is a striking example,
Johann Johann Gottfried Tulla around 1800,
responsible for a treaty called
the Rectification of the Rhine
among all the adjacent Rhine nations.
The wonderful word
Rectification of the Rhine
is a wonderful term as if God had somehow,
if you'll excuse the expression fucked up
and that the Rhine had to be rectified
from its original form.
It was an actual treaty,
it eliminated meanders,
removed barriers in the channel,
it confined the river to a single bed
with no braids to a uniform
width where possible
through a uniform depth and
a uniform speed of current.
That is to say the effort
was to turn the Rhine
into a canal so far as it
was possible, predictable,
uniform, straight,
a Burnett Willy's principle
of pressure and turbulence,
to take a variable and
turn it into a constant.
The Rhine was shortened by 105 kilometers
and it lost 80% of its
floodplain in the upper Rhine.
I'm going to skip some things.
I should add, there's the Rhine.
And you can see the old Rhine,
and the new reformed Rhine as
it was shortened over time.
That section that I
skipped over by the way
is a section on the way
in which people running away
from States have run to marshes
and wetlands because they're
extremely hard to please,
whether it's the Marsh Arabs,
whether it's the Great Dismal Swamp
that held more than
6,000 and runaway slaves
at the beginning of the
Civil War, marshes and swamps
have been in, if you
like refuges over time
for people wanting to evade the state
for one reason or another.
The result of the
Rectification of the Rhine
is that a drop of water that
falls in Switzerland now
takes only three days to get to Holland,
whereas before it took
something like 10 days.
The results of this
for catastrophic floods
in a high water are something
that you can appreciate
and the degree to which a big
rainfall is quickly channeled
into the river because of
the changes of its banks
and the changes in the channel.
George Perkins Marsh understood this
as a simple matter of physics,
say a river has a 1600 mile
course, say the natural channel
drops 800 feet from the origin to the sea,
that's a drop of six inches to the mile.
By shortening the river
and cutting off meanders,
let's say you make it
only 1200 miles long.
Then the pitch is increased
eight inches to the mile,
it's only two inches,
it's one quarter steeper
but it has tremendous effects on the speed
on how much silt it carries on the height
of probable flood crests
on the erosion of banks.
And if you then try to minimize floods
by preventing lateral movement
of river water, by levees
you increase the amount of
silt carried to the mouth,
the silting up of the Dutch
estuary is a good example.
As Aldo Leopold, once wrote,
"The Germans had a fondness
for unnecessary outdoor geometry."
Other simplifications are
hydroelectric dams and irrigation
which create changed lakes, still water,
which destroys fish
migrations in both directions
and prevents the natural
conveyor belt of silt downriver
even for national (indistinct) of a river.
It raises the question of when
is the river still a river?
How many things can you do to a river
and still call it a river?
I once had a colleague in
Wisconsin who had a cat,
and since I was in Wisconsin
for the better part of a decade
I would visit them, this family
often, I will not name them.
And the cat, somehow the
its tail had been docked
for some reason, it had been neutered
and shortly in the year, before I left
as it was tearing up the
furniture, it had been declawed.
And my wife and I on the
way back from this visit,
wondered to one another how
many things could you take away
from a cat and still have a cat?
And somehow the decline of a cat seemed
somehow to be over the red line.
But I think it's worth saying what happens
in the engineering of river
which has never completely
successful, by the way,
when you try to turn it
into a canal, a pipe,
a chain of lakes that can be
used for irrigation and so on.
One of the results of this
effort to control a river,
this is the Yellow River near Kaifeng.
And because of the use
of levees over time,
it's a rich agricultural area,
and as the river carry more silt
and therefore the bed of the
river got higher and higher
and higher in order to
prevent catastrophic floods
the levees were built
higher and higher and higher
over time.
So that now at Kaifeng, at
least when this book was written
from which the image is taken
the river was 33 feet above
the surrounding floodplain.
So you may wanna call that a river,
but to me, it looks a
lot more like an aqueduct
and it's an aqueduct that's been made
by the engineering of the river
that gradually increased its bed
the height of its bed and
necessitated, if you wanted
to protect the farmland around
it, or tax paying farmers
and so on then you built the levees
higher and higher and higher,
and it set the stage
for catastrophic floods.
So when a flood then does occur,
it's likely to be a
massive and enormous flood.
And I want to wind up here
and this requires me to vastly shorten
the last part of the talk,
but I'll try to summarize it briefly.
There's something in medicine
called iatrogenic illnesses
which are a fancy term
for the cure being worse than the disease.
It's the superbugs that
one finds in hospitals,
that in a sense by trying
to stop small infections,
with antibiotics, you create
the selection pressures
that increase over time
the bacteria that are able
to survive these insults
and poisons and still survive
and then you create superbugs
that thrive in hospitals and so on.
I won't go into this,
but iatrogenic medicine
is extremely important
and a tremendous number of the
hospitalizations that occur
are in a sense the results of treatment
rather than the illness itself.
So I want to argue that the effort
to prevent small infections
results in large infections,
the results to prevent small floods,
and there you have political lock-in
because representatives want
to preserve the population
because they're paying taxes
because they vote for them
and they'll do anything they can
to preserve the real estate values.
You get this political lock-in as well,
and the result is then,
and here forest fires are a good analogy.
The effort for 60 years
by the forest service
to prevent all fires resulted
in catastrophic fires
because of the buildup
of combustible materials,
and the prevention of natural fires.
And then in the same way
there's an iatrogenic process
in which the effort to
prevent small floods
has resulted in large floods.
The 1993, a flood of the
Mississippi and Missouri
is a good example.
And now the most, the
smallest, most hesitant
and timid efforts are being
made to restore floodplains
and wetlands that have been destroyed,
but to an extent that
is so trivial and timid
that it has not made
much of a dent in the,
if you like the death of
rivers or the maiming of rivers
or the taxidermy of rivers
that we experienced.
Let me stop there, happy
to take any questions.
- Thank you, Jim, for
that fascinating talk.
Let's take a moment and
thank Jim for the talk
if you to take a moment to clap.
So I don't mistake your
clapping for your raised hands.
I'll take a moment.
So what we'll do here is
if you can raise your hand
using the hand raise function
of Zoom, please do that.
If you can't figure out how to do that
send a text to me via the chat,
and if you can't figure out how to do that
wave your hand wildly on the screen
and hopefully I'll see it eventually,
and I'll keep track of it.
The first hand that was up was Paul Sarno,
after that it will be Michael Dove
and then I'll type a list
of the order in the chat.
So let's start with Paul
and please keep your
questions relatively brief
if you don't mind because I'm sure
there's gonna be a lot of
questions on the table, so thanks.
- Hi Paul
- Jim, thank you very much.
I have a layman's question.
It sounds like from what you're saying
it's not a good idea to dam up rivers.
And if that's true, does that mean,
one of the major reasons I thought
for damming up the river,
is you can get a lot of hydropower
and that that was relatively clean energy.
Am I correct in those suppositions
that it's not a good idea
to dam up rivers and not a good idea
to dam up even tributaries?
- Well, if you're focused on
how much power you can generate
relatively cleanly for homo sapiens,
the answer is you're right.
If you're interested in
the life world of the river
and the migrating fish and the life forms
that depend on the natural
processes of the river
and of its floods and
so on, then for them,
it's almost certain death.
And so it depends
whether that's the point,
it depends on whether you're focusing,
I suppose wind and solar are rather better
than hydroelectric.
And there are, by the
way, small dams, a run
of the river dams.
I mean, there's a typology of dams
which are more or less destructive as dams
in terms of the natural
processes of the river.
So the world commission on dams
actually has a set of
principles that it established.
This was after the normal dam protests
for dams that are well okay,
if not entirely approved
- Thanks Jim, thanks
Paul for that question,
and Michael.
- Thanks, Eric.
This was fascinating, Jim.
I was interested in your
likening of the impact
of flooding to the impacts
of fire in the hills.
So this gives us two pulses to compare,
a pulse from wet to dry to wet
and in the hills a pulse
from field to forest,
back to field so two different pulses.
And it seems like these
pulses have been problematic
for land tenure,
at least the way outsiders
viewed land tenure.
So I'm wondering if you can place
the tenure real
implications of these pulses
in the longer history of
land tenure for fixed land
within which these seem to
be, as I said, problematic
- I'm thinking.
I suppose, maybe this
is what you're implying
in your comments, that I was interested
in the nutrient cycle of silt versus fire
and the way in which it
provided the basis for cropping.
But you raise the question,
which is even more interesting
in many ways, which is
our idea of property
that is based on fixed borders
and fixed tenure and titles
when in fact, in the flood
recession agriculture
that I'm talking about the
land is shifting all the time
under the pressure of floods
and the deposition of
silted sand and gravel
for/and burn agriculture,
shifting agriculture.
It requires that in a sense,
the fields to be moved
but it's within as you know
a lot better than I do,
it's within a fixed compass by and large
or if you like a rotation of fallowing.
And as again, what's interesting
is in terms of customary land tenure,
the people who are not
planning particular Sweden
are likely to have recognized rights
to the things that are popping
up in the Sweden anyway,
and the right to return
to her, is that correct?
- [Michael] Yes.
- I'm not sure I answered
your question, Michael,
I wouldn't like to hear a lecture
from you on the comparison.
- That was great, thanks, Jim.
- I think we can have a
special workshop on this topic
with Michael and Jim
meeting, head to head.
We have a question from Jacob.
- Hi, Professor Scott, that
was a really interesting,
I really appreciated hearing
about all the river meandering issues,
but just something
that's certainly been on my mind recently,
I guess I'm gonna keep my
question short as requested,
I'm wondering about the implications
of a world of real liberated rivers
where they're permitted to meander,
they're permitted to be dynamic
and they're permitted to
have their flood cycles.
The implications for human
settlement, urbanization, town
and city location patterns,
implications for transportation.
I was struck by your example
of the temporary seasonal bamboo bridge,
I've seen bridges like that
in (indistinct) in India
at a particular river location,
where during some times
at a year, you get across on a ferry boat,
and another times of year,
you have to use an elephant
to wade across the elephant swim
in the deep part of the channel
with people on its back.
And then at another time of
year, when it's appropriate
you have this temporary bridge.
And that's really neat in
that particular location,
it's a village called (indistinct).
But people were talking about reliberating
the entire lower Rhine or
the entire lower Mississippi.
What happens to town
in a city settlements?
What happens to road infrastructure?
How do people get from point A to point B,
even if rivers are constantly meandering
and that means that sandbars
are constantly being rearranged.
So even things like having
regular ferry routes
might be difficult.
So I'm wondering how could
you kind of reintegrate
those kinds of human needs
with these with reliberated rivers?
- It's a great question
and my job is to diagnose
where we are not how we get out of it.
And so what's interesting
to me for example,
is that this is actually
covered kind of brilliantly
and Mark Elvin's "The
Retreat of the Elephants",
since you mentioned elephants.
The difference between,
there were traditionally
in China river masters,
and there were two schools
of river mastery, a Confucian
School and a Daois School.
And the Confucian school
was sort of like the Army Corps
of Engineers, more or less
let's make the river do
what we want it to do.
And the Daois School was to try to work
within the limits of rivers
and natural movement.
So they would have, for
example, gates or sluices
that would be over spills sluices,
that would only open when
the pressure of the water
reached a certain level naturally
without any human intervention,
they were engineered that way.
The other example that is in a combination
I think it's above St. Louis
on the Mississippi River
in which a whole series of
areas were recently developed
and were destroyed something
like two or three times
in a course of 20 years.
And the result was actually
to forbid rebuilding in those areas.
First of all, it was hard
to get insurance for them
as you might imagine,
the third time around.
And the result was that you had this land
was actually very good agricultural land
and very good for sports field land.
It just couldn't have
permanent structures on it,
so most of the year it
was perfectly usable
but it was unoccupied and
a potential floodplain
in those areas when the river rose.
So it was, if you like an overspill
and it ended up protecting
downriver settlements
that were otherwise in danger.
if there were not this overspill area.
There's a history by the way
of struggle between settlements
on opposite sides of a
river that's in flood stage
of who's going to break
the dykes on which side.
And so here's a whole Japanese literature
on people rolling over from
one village to break the dykes
on their competing settlement
on the other side of the river,
so that it releases the pressure on them,
and in a sense there's I think
a series of accommodation.
So the problem the
reason why I don't think
it has a solution in your terms
is because of political
lock-in that you have
if you like a whole series
of investment, population,
congressional districts, industries
and so on that are built on the floodplain
and that can, in a sense,
mandate the public expenditure
in order to protect them,
and also lobby the government
for reduced insurance rates
in order to protect them
with the result, of course,
that you set yourself up
for larger disasters over time I think.
- Thank you.
- Thanks, Jim and thanks
Jacob for that question.
Now we have a question
from Ian Baird who's
coming in from Madison
probably defending the cats of Madison
as well as having a question.
- Well, I won't make any
comments about the cats
but I will say that that was a great talk
and thank you so much for that.
I just wanted to add one
aspect to what you presented,
which relates to an idea of energy.
And when I talk about energy,
I'm not talking about
electricity, that's produced
or energy that's given to human use.
I'm talking about the energy of the river
when it flows down stream.
And one of the things
that happens in the water,
and also in the Mekong where I work
is when the fish migrate upstream
many of them migrate upstream,
and then they spawn upstream.
And then it coincides with the increasing
of the monsoon rains
and the increasing of
the size of the river.
And the energy of the river actually helps
those small larvae that are born
to flow down the river.
And one of the the huge
impacts of hydropower dams,
big dams is actually they stop the energy.
What they do is they, you
think the dams produce energy,
well, they do, but they stop the energy
in the sense that they
often create reservoirs.
And so those fish or
larvae that are downstream
all of a sudden reach the reservoir
and then the speed slows
down and these larvae,
kind of drop out and often
get trapped in the reservoir,
and even if they could make it
through the turbines further
downstream, they don't
because of the disruption
of the energy flow
of the river itself or the life pulse,
if you might put it that way.
So I think that that's just
another way of, I think,
adding to what already
a great presentation
of the ecological aspects and
how they're very much related.
I mean, the Mekong itself has
the largest freshwater fishery
in the world, and this destruction of flow
and similarly with a Wadi
if they would have built
a dam on the main stream
or even on many tributaries
for that matter,
has really a devastating impact.
- Right, I wanna start by
saying, I've learned a lot
about the Mekong and about rivers
from reading some of
your work on the Mekong.
I think it's not appreciated,
we were very much aware of these days
of 4,000 mile migrations by birds annually
and the importance of
these flyaways and so on.
And I think we don't realize
the extraordinary distances
of anadromous and I
forget what the antonym is
for that fish that breed in fresh water
and go to salt water.
- Diatomaceous?
- Right, the extent of
migrations is of distances
that are astounding, just as challenging
as they are for birds of
four, five, six, 7,000 miles.
I mean, the movement of eels, for example,
in the Pacific and so on.
And so it's as if you
somehow had a barrier
that destroyed the flyway
for bird migrations,
every time you put in a dam
not only is the still
water much less nutritious
and much less biotically
alive than moving water
but you also prevent
the movement, nutrition
and the in a sense, the life
world, this is their medium,
for them, the river is their life world.
That's why we may not wanna sacrifice
at the last ounce of kilowatts
that we can get from a dam
but there are other ways we
can get much of our power
without destroying the life world
of a whole spectrum of
species that depend on it.
And who knows what their
effects are in the long run,
if they're lost.
- Thanks, Jim.
So we have a few more minutes
and we have several more questions.
I wanna ask Jim, do you mind continuing
to answer questions for
another eight minutes or so?
- [Jim] Sure, of course.
- Okay, so the next
question from John Sidel,
after John is Michael Vann, just let me,
after John will be Michael
Vann, then Allen Potkin
Jamie Anderson and Hans Steinmueller.
So you could see there's a
fair number of questions,
let's have John ask his
and then we'll see how
far we get in that list.
- Hi John.
- Hi, Jim, nice to see you.
You're the last person I've
had an indoor meal with
other than my family
- (laughs) On March 16th or something.
- Yeah, exactly.
Brilliant talk, wonderful link
to get a sense of the forthcoming book.
And one thing I was struck by
was the sort of characteristic reference
to a variety of different rivers
and commonalities across them.
But I guess my question is
whether there reaches a point
in human history, recent history,
where we find that what
happens in one river,
happens in other rivers
not only simultaneously more or less,
but in an interconnected fashion.
So for example, we know from Mark Elvin,
what happens to the Pearl River
Delta with silt cultivation
but then that has knock on effects
in terms of stimulating demand
for rice from elsewhere.
So this then impacts on
the Mekong, arguably maybe,
in the Red River Delta as well.
And it could even be that if
you go back to the conditions
that stimulate French
demand for Chinese silk
that they come from things
that happened in rivers
the (indistinct), the
Rhone in France, who knows,
it might be there, I'm not sure.
But in other words,
does there come a point
where what happens in one river,
happens in all rivers or
that that interconnectedness
with steamboats and otherwise takes on
a kind of a catalytic effect,
kind of multiplier effect
so you can't study one river
without running into the
impact of other rivers
that the histories are
intertwined as it were.
- That's a rich question and could go
in many different directions
in terms of talking about it.
It seems to me, it's useful actually
to once you get steam power
and you get these enormous
sort of barges that can
carry huge bulk goods
on navigable rivers, like the Mississippi
and the Rhine and so
on, and they're designed
and engineered or transformed
for exactly that purpose.
They carry both goods,
especially they are superior
to any other form of transportation
where that's available
for all goods that have
a relatively low value
per unit weight and volume.
So that, for example, that's
why the lower Mississippi
is the cotton cultivation, right?
And its consequences,
the shipping of grain
and of course gravel and stone
and charcoal and timber, et cetera.
And so somehow it seems to me
that both the invention of steam power
and the capacity to move
an enormous amount of cargo
with relatively little friction
because that's what the
river provides is important.
But it seems to me that our
capacity to change the rivers,
that's why I went out of my
way to emphasize dynamite
and reinforce concrete
an earth moving machinery
because our capacity to make rivers
do what we want them to do
in order to serve as vehicles
commerce or transportation
are dependent on those late 19th century
and early 20th century.
And let me also add, Ian
would know this, and many
of you would know this from
work on Asia, that in fact
and it's not just the Chinese,
but it's especially the Chinese,
there is a dam industrial complex
in which having dammed
every river in China,
all of these engineers on the capital
are looking to build dams in
Southeast Asia, in Africa,
just the way the Italians and
Norwegians wanna build tunnels
everywhere on the world.
So there is, if you like,
there's an enormous emphasis
because you can prove
certain benefits are there.
We could go into the cost
benefit analysis that is so bogus
with respect to the
organization, the rationale
for dams in terms of
their economic benefits.
But it seems to me that
there is, if you like,
a kind of international
combine of engineers
major corporations, state,
and non-state corporations
for whom river engineering
is their business
and they have an enormous
amount of influence,
it provides jobs, benefits,
capital, and so on,
and so that shouldn't be
overlooked, I don't think.
- Thanks, Jim.
Now we have a question from Michael Vann.
- Hi, thank you so much for
the great talk Professor Scott
a big fan of your work.
Also, thank you to Yale
for making this public.
This is really the Zoom
or the COVID silver lining
for a lot of us is the Zoom talks.
Just real quick question,
if the answer is no,
move on to the next
question, but if it's, yes,
I'd like to hear a
little more, do you find,
in your analysis of the rivers,
the term Anthropocene useful
for categorizing historical
development, if not fine,
but if yes, what does the
study of rivers tell us
about conceptualizing the Anthropocene?
- Unfortunately, the answer
is yes, that is to say
now I have to elaborate, don't I?
Well, one of the ways in
which I understand this
is to take George Perkins
Marsh's book from 1864.
And so he's operating at a time,
before at least the real
growth of steam power
and he understands the way in
which deforestation and so on.
So it's what I would describe
as a lighter, thin Anthropocene
that he's describing
in the way in which we've changed rivers.
And it seems to me
that because of the
technological innovations
that I mentioned with the
dynamite, a reinforced concrete,
et cetera, is that our
capacity to intervene
and reshape the landscape
and the hydrology of rivers
has grown at an exponential rate.
And that as a result
it's become an important
political resource
for lots of States.
I think the Burmese military,
as a specialist are building
roads and dams and bridges,
basically that's all it
does as near as I can tell,
so like an engineering,
military regime say,
as if the Army Corps of Engineers
took over the United States.
But it seems to me that yes, I
mean, it's hard to understand
what's happened to rivers
without these anthropogenic interventions.
And the fact which I
think is often overlooked,
is that in 1750,
there were only three
quarters of a billion of us
and now we're going on 8 billion.
So it's not as if you know the arthropods
that are screwing up the planet
are eight times more numerous
than they were in 1750.
So that all by itself
is an enormous burden
on the resources that a river can provide.
- Thanks, given the time I'm gonna ask
if Alan Potkin, Jamie
Anderson and Han Steinmueller
might ask their questions together
so that we can kind of see
if there's a thread linking them together.
I'm sorry to do that to all of you,
I know you've been waiting
patiently, but it is 1:22.
And when we're finished,
I'll leave the Zoom open
for some informal chats and conversation
for those who have the energy to hang out,
I'll do that for a while too.
But so, Alan, I think you
were first and then Jamie
and then Han's, if you don't
mind going in succession.
- Yeah, I'll be as quick as I can.
Several years ago, I actually
did a considerable amount
of boat travel on the
Irrawaddy and made it as far
above the proposed
confluence them at Myitsone
as foreigners were allowed to go
and then traveled by boat
all the way down by steamer
all the way down to Mandalay.
I checked every fish market that I could
and essentially there were no
large native rivers species
for sale in any of the fish markets.
And there were hardly
any small fishing boats
compared especially to the Mekong
anywhere along the Irrawaddy.
Okay, that said Burma has 4,000 megawatts
of hydropower of installed capacity,
some coal, mostly hydropower,
that's a trivial amount,
and that's the main disincentive
against economic development.
The Myitsone projects
alone would add something
like 15 to 25,000 megawatts to that 4,000.
And you might wanna look at the ebook,
if you go into the chat file
you'll find a link to my
online ebook on that subject.
I love rivers the same as
everybody else here does
but sometimes it's necessary
to get real with human needs.
So pick that up, however you see fit
but do look at the chat link
with my ebook on that subject.
Thanks.
- I shall do just very briefly,
I actually spent the better part
of a week in the Mandalay
fish markets, right?
Talking to old fish summers
and trying to figure out
the naming of fishes and keeping all
of this straight and an
enormously difficult thing,
even if you're working in
English or French or on Burmese,
and the names of all the
fish were unfamiliar to me.
But it was clear to me
that there was actually
a lot of the fish sold
in the Mandalay market
are fish that come from the Delta
and not from the river itself.
So I think it's true that there is not
a sort of huge fishing industry
at least as I experienced it.
I think that, well,
the question is whether
the Myitson dam is, if you
wanna make an argument,
in favor of hydroelectric power,
and it's a plausible argument
if you're concentrating on a homo sapiens
as I mentioned earlier.
Then it behooves us if
I stand in your shoes
for the time being to figure
out how one can generate
in a cost-effective way as
much hydroelectric power
as possible with as little damage
to the natural hydrology of a river
and the lifeforms in the
river and the Myitsone Dam,
I think was not an optimal
solution to that problem.
- Go ahead, Jamie.
- Okay, well, Professor Scott
thank you for your wonderful talk.
This is probably a big question
but I'll just put it out
there, looking at the rivers
prior to our ability to dam
up rivers or reroute rivers,
so humankind's ability to
kind of alter the effect.
Do you see the human
settlement along the Irrawaddy
responded to these transition
between this kind of aquatic
terrestrial transition zone
that you had talked about?
Do you see, historically would
we look for the footprint
of kind of human settlement in cycles,
did they understand the
cycles and the changes,
I'm thinking about the Red
River, but I was wondering
how in the Irrawaddy, if you
saw any evidence of that.
So when we actually look for
evidence of human settlement
we should look in this kind
of patterns of river usage
or the river itself, as opposed to-
- It's a good point, my
understanding is that
like for many other rivers,
that if you're looking for
early human settlements,
you're looking at,
and that's true for many of
the Delta towns, by the way
they happen to be on little bluffs
that are above the floodplain
and relatively safe
from the annual floods
and storms and so on.
And I think that's true for
the upper Irrawaddy as well,
I'm not as conversant with the archeology
of the early settlements along
the Irrawaddy as I might be,
but that's my impression
that you don't want to look,
at the, if you like the, the floodplain
is sort of rich floodplain
soils but you want to look
to nearby and what we're
talking about things
like things that are 20, 30 meters higher,
or are no more often than
the surrounding floodplain,
it's my guess.
- Great, and Hans will
have the last question
before we stop the recording
and then just we'll have
a open few minutes together as well.
Go ahead, Hans.
- Thanks, hi, that was a
extremely inspiring talk,
and my question is about complexity.
I found, in general, I'm very sympathetic
to this opposition between
the kind of simplification
and leaving the river to its complexity,
and that simplification in general
had bad and negative consequences
and little kind of prevention efforts
created the possibility
for much bigger floods,
but I'm wondering if this is always true
and whether or not sometimes
we can also grant rivers
as the possibility to recreate
new forms of complexity
or to adapt to new situations.
And one reference I had
that was kind of the Rhine and Heidegger,
because actually in this
essay on technology,
which he wrote in the 1950s
the Rhine plays a crucial role.
And specifically the opposition
between the pre-rectified Rhine,
where poets such as
Heidegger look at the Rhine
as authentic kind of feeling
and engagement with the world,
and then when he, in
1950, looks at the Rhine
the only thing he sees is
dams, hydroelectric dams,
and he looks at one specifically
and says this is what modern
technology does to the world
that makes the world
inauthentic unreal kind of.
So it's like, like you said,
you know that's where you cut off
all the four legs of the cot
it's not a river any longer,
it's something else,
but Heidegger assessment
seems to be very black
and white in the sense
that modern technology
totally destroys everything
in that there's no more
complexity and it's inauthentic.
And my question is whether or not
this is kind of taking it too far.
- The question is whether Heidegger's term
inauthentic is the appropriate one to use.
I mean, depending on the
perspective one might want to adopt
and there are several
perspectives that are plausible.
One might say that the river
was relatively impoverished,
in the sense that its biodiversity
was drastically reduced,
if you like the wetlands
that were if you like,
the nursery beds of most of the life
along the Rhine were destroyed.
And I think if you want
to then like Heidegger,
concentrate on the human
produced landscape of dams
and levees and so on,
then you get if you like,
the inauthentic
architectural interventions
of homo sapiens, sort of,
so I see why he wants to
call them inauthentic.
I was impressed, this is
something of a slight diversion,
but I was impressed with
the Japanese practice
which was abandoned at some point
but an older practice of river management
in which Japanese river
managers, engineers
would hypothecate a kind of
intervention in the river
for human purposes,
they were not interested
in the wildlife in particular.
But they also understood
that they did not understand
the behavior of the river entirely.
And so what they would do
is to build a small weir
where they would imagine they
would build a larger weir
and they would build it and
then they would, if you like
stand back for two or three years
and see what the river did with
it, how it changed the flow,
how everything changed around it,
whether it accumulated silt,
what happened down river
and up were from it and so on.
And then they would in a sense,
design their next intervention
which could be the removal
of the weir for that matter,
they would design their next intervention
by what they had learned in the interim
by not assuming that
they understood the river
completely at the
beginning of the exercise.
And I thought there's a kind of, I dunno,
Daoist humility if you like to this way,
of understanding how to an
engineer and landscape a river
that sounds to me rather more
scientifically defensible
given the facts that the hydrology,
I mean the effort to
understand the hydrology
of the lower Irrawaddy scientifically
as the creation of islands in the Delta,
there just too many variables
to make it a scientific
formula and all the more reason
to observe carefully what
happens at a particular instance,
knowing that it's not
gonna be exactly replicated
in the next instance.
I hope that's helpful.
- Thank you, Jim.
I think we should give Jim
a little bit of a rest here
and join me in thanking him
for such a fantastic talk
and wonderful conversation.
So thank you, Jim.
- [Jim] Thank you.